madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal au proche-orient quelques
fragiles signes d'apaisement
il sert à rafah demande la
reconstruction du tombeau de joseph
saccagé hier une cellule de crise entre
israéliens et palestiniens avaient
décidé sur la question de la sécurité à
gaza
mais la situation reste terriblement
préoccupante ehud barak accentue la
pression sur la syrie et l'autorité
palestinienne
c'est demain que les sanctions
économiques fera qu'en frappant la
yougoslavie devrait être levé par
l'union européenne un pays dévasté
exemple qui cherche à se reconstruire
formule 1 le grand prix du japon avec la
victoire de ferrari après 21 ans
d'attentes l'enthousiasmé des
supporteurs michael schumacher obtient
son troisième titre mondial
musique avec le talent de cette jeune
diva romaine cecilia bartoli son dernier
disque survivent elle dit sa rage c'est
là une voix d'exception
100 portraits dans cette édition à 24
heures de la fin de l'ultimatum lancé
par ehud barak les violences ont repris
dans la bande de gaza après une courte
pause qui laissait espérer que la
tension allait retomber l'armée
israélienne est en état d' alerte
maximum et le restera pendant les fêtes
de kippour qui viennent de commencer des
patrouilles appuyés par des chars kadri
les points névralgiques quelques signes
d'apaisement tout de même avec le début
de la reconstruction du tombeau de
joseph saccagé hier par les palestiniens
près de 100 perd l'armée israélienne en
alerte maximum depuis l'enlèvement hier
par le hezbollah de trois de ses soldats
salle acheminent des renforts à la
frontière avec le liban
tout au long de la journée des chars des
blindés des troupes d'élite ont pris
position
une nouvelle fois de nombreux incidents
ont eu lieu à gaza et en cisjordanie
des affrontements sporadiques et moins
violents tout cas que ceux de ses 10
derniers jours en début d'après midi
près de la colonie juive de netzarim la
police palestinienne a évacué les
manifestants
dans ce même secteur l'armée israélienne
a détruit deux immeubles qui servait de
poste d'attaquant jeunes palestiniens
sur ces images des caméras de
surveillance de l'armée on voit
l'explosion des deux buildings toujours
dans la bande de gaza la nuit dernière
un autobus israélien a été mitraillé
vers minuit
neuf passagers ont été blessés
des échanges de tirs ont également eu
lieu tout au long de la nuit à hébron à
naplouse en début de soirée plusieurs
centaines de manifestants israéliens ont
détruit une ancienne mosquée ils
entendaient ainsi protester contre la
destruction la veille du tombeau de
joseph par des palestiniens tous les
arabes en fin d'après midi le premier
ministre israélien a rappelé qu'il
donnait deux jours aux palestiniens pour
arrêter les violences
sinon dit-il le processus de paix sera
caduc et nous engagerons alors toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour protéger
nos compatriotes et nos soldats
côté palestinien on rejette cet
ultimatum nabil chaath un ministre
palestinien a déclaré devant la presse
qu'il n'y avait qu'un seul agresseur
les israéliens ce soir malgré l'impasse
dans le dialogue entre autorités
israéliennes et palestiniennes
on semblait toutefois noté sur le
terrain quelques signes d'apaisement
et depuis la tombée du jour tous les
israéliens commencent à célébrer ce jour
du grand pardon la fête la plus sacré de
la religion juive
et c'est dans une ambiance
particulièrement tendue qu'ici ou là on
se prépare à cette journée de jeunes
réservé la prière derniers préparatifs
ce dimanche à hébron et à jérusalem qui
ont suivi alan salvan et gilles jacquier
dans l'allégresse
on fait vite vite ces dernières courses
à 16h39 précise la vie va s'arrêter à
jérusalem pour le kippour jusqu'à lundi
soir même heure où l'on servira le
poulet sacrifier la veille selon un
rituel immuable un peu compliqué dans
son appartement
menahem gourari prépare la fête la plus
sacré du judaïsme
une fête qu'il aurait aimé plus sereine
c'est une fête que nous allons
accueillir peut-être avec plus de
d'angoissé et d'anxiété qu'auparavant il
faut absolument expliquer aux enfants
comment ça se fait que ils préparent
cette fête alors qu'on tire sur eux pour
tirs sur les maisons que les familles ne
peuvent pas rester dans leur salon parce
que les fenêtres du salon donne
directement sur une ligne de 1120 ligne
de mire dans le collimateur de palestine
à 40 km de là à kiryat arba
implantations juives qui surplombe la
ville arabe d'hébron où se trouve le
caveau des patriarches un des points les
plus chauds de ces derniers jours on
prépare aussi le kippour 1 qui pour sans
concession dans le climat de violence
actuelle
il existe un dicton famille dit qu à
balai au regard à acheter leurs gosses
celui qui vient te tue est assassiné tu
vois tu dois le devancer et te des
footeux défendre en bas dans la ville
d'hébron les soldats se prépare tout
inclus pour de combat au bout de la
ligne de mire dans ce champ de pierres
il y a les barricades
le quartier arabe et ceux qui au nom du
coran applique le même dicton
talmudiques
l'aviation israélienne a survolé
beyrouth dans la matinée ce pour la
première fois depuis la fin du mois de
mai date à laquelle l'armée israélienne
s'était retirée du liban sud le liban
multiplie ses patrouilles terrestres et
maritimes dans une ambiance électrique
amplifié par les obsèques des
palestiniens tuyères reste la question
cruciale du sort réservé aux trois
soldats de tsahal capturé hier par le
hezbollah et dont israël rendra
responsables la syrie et le liban
nos envoyés spéciaux dorothée olliéric
et patrick voix se sont rendus dans les
camps de sabra et chatila pour
rencontrer des palestiniens et des
responsables et cela sous camp
palestinien a été le théâtre d'un des
pires massacres c'était en 1982 à sabra
et chatila la mort de 800 palestine tous
reviennent de l'enterrement de deux des
leurs tué hier par les i drive pour eux
le passé est encore extrêmement
douloureux et le présent les révoltes à
elle c'est du terrorisme
c'est inacceptable nous sommes un peuple
libre
on trouve ça très bien que le hezbollah
est enlevé les trois soldats israël et
si le hezbollah en demande de l'aider on
est prêt l'un des dirigeants du
mouvement chiite hezbollah a rencontré
cet après midi et des routes
le représentant de la croix rouge j'ai
demandé au hezbollah de rencontrer dès
que possible
les trois prisonniers
ce matin le quotidien libanais as safir
a publié plusieurs photos de l'opération
commando du hezbollah ici on voit le
camion où les trois soldats israéliens
patrouillaient
aujourd'hui le hezbollah a confirmé que
sa formation était prête à échanger les
trois soldats israéliens contre les
libanais détenus en israël
notre chef du mouvement grippe son
discours est encore plus fins et
musculaires si jamais la miss valiant
commence n'importe quelle opération
contre le liban la réponse de la
résistance islamique cela et nous sommes
nous incitons tous les arabes ou les
musulmans et tous les chrétiens à lutter
contre israël
aujourd'hui aucun incident majeur n'a
été déploré à la frontière avec israël
en revanche l'aviation de tsahal a
survolé à plusieurs offices beyrouth
l'heure est aussi à l'intimidation et
toute la communauté internationale à
vous son extrême inquiétude face à cette
escalade de violence qui pourrait
déboucher sur la guerre partout les
appels au calme se multiplient en milieu
d'après midi cette déclaration qui se
veut rassurant devenu de damas et qui
affirme que ni le liban ni la syrie ni
le hezbollah ne veulent déclencher la
guerre mais au moyen-orient les esprits
sont chauffés à blanc pascal golomer
c'est pour défendre le liban les
palestiniens et la nation arabe pour
appeler à la vengeance aussi contre
israël et les états unis que près de
5000 personnes ont manifesté aujourd'hui
dans les rues de bagdad
des slogans repris par le pouvoir
irakien lui-même qui appellent
aujourd'hui à la guertin manifestation
aussi au maroc beaucoup plus imposante
ils étaient plusieurs centaines de
milliers dans les rues de rabat à avoir
répondu à l'appel de l'association de
soutien à la lutte palestinienne
la plus importante marches organisées
dans le pays depuis la guerre du golfe
le premier ministre lui-même
abderrahmane youssoufi avait tenu à y
participer en egypte enfin ce sont les
étudiants qui ont forcé les portes de
l'université islamique du caire avec
pour la première fois des slogans
favorables au hezbollah libanais la
manifestation a été dispersée par les
forces de l'ordre
au même moment hosni moubarak appelé les
pays arabes à la modération
selon le chef de l'état égyptien qui
recevait il ya quelques jours le
président syrien bachar el-assad
la situation est grave et réclame une
réaction sage c'est d'ailleurs au nom de
la modération que les états unis n'ont
pas opposer leur veto la nuit dernière à
une résolution des nations unies
résolution condamnant les violences et
en particulier l usage excessif de la
force contre les palestiniens
richard holbrooke l'ambassadeur
américain c'est seulement abstenu
les 14 autres membres du conseil de
sécurité ont voté pour bill clinton lui
n'a pas quitté son bureau à la maison
blanche
il pourrait rejoindre ce soir par
téléphone bachar el assad le président
syrien dont le rôle est plus que jamais
essentiel pour une résolution de la
crise et en direct de jérusalem à la
salle vont entre violence et signe
d'apaisement la situation semble confuse
incertaine à 24 heures de l'ultimatum
d'ehud barak
oui écouter le hasard du calendrier a
voulu que nous soyons entrés dans cette
période du kippour une période sacrée où
aucun israélien n'a envie de faire la
guerre c'est vrai hier soir on pensait
être au bord du conflit on pensait qu'il
pourrait même se déclencher dans la nuit
et bien force est de constater que cette
journée a été la plus calme ou disons en
tout cas la moins violente depuis cette
reprise de l'intifada la première en
tout cas où il n'y a pas eu de mort on a
vu il ya eu des gestes de bonne volonté
en particulier la reconstruction de la
tombe de joseph les deux parties les
militaires des deux parties se parlent
directement ou par l'intermédiaire de la
cia il n'y a pas eu d'incident notable
non plus sur la frontière nord d'israël
la frontière israélo libanaise alors ça
veut pas dire que la guerre n'aura pas
lieu
cela veut simplement dire que l'on a ce
soir éviter le pire
merci alain de chalvron et en france la
demande expresse des dirigeants de la
communauté juive
jacques chirac ce matin et lionel jospin
cet après midi ce centre entretenu avec
les principaux représentants du crif
l'appel à la raison et l'inquiétude de
la communauté juive qui concerne bien
sûr la situation en israël et dans les
territoires mais aussi en france où des
incidents ont opposé hier soir jeunes
arabes des jeunes juifs en banlieue
parisienne
philippe boisserie marie pierre
cassignard devant la grande synagogue de
nice ils étaient un millier à s'être
donnés rendez vous ce matin pour
manifester leur solidarité avec israël
la profanation du tombeau de joseph à
naplouse suscitent un vif émoi tout
comme le rôle joué par la france lors
des récentes négociations
israélo-palestiniennes de paris les
modèles ou de barack accusant jacques
chirac d'avoir encouragé un regain de
terrorisme ont laissé des traces
au point qu'une délégation de la
communauté juive avait demandé à être
reçues au plus vite par le président de
la république après une heure et demie
d'explication le souhait d'une position
équilibrée fait écho à la volonté
d'apaisement du chef de l'état la france
doit rester un médiateur et ne pas
prendre parti c'est ce que nous sommes
venus dire aussi au président de la
république parce que si elle se
départissait de son rôle si elle ne
restait pas dans un équilibre
eh bien il n'y aurait plus la confiance
de la part des israéliens envers la
france ou en vers l'europe
et ça sera peut-être pire deux heures
plus tard c'est au tour du premier
ministre de recevoir la délégation
mais pas question de jouer sur les
différences d'appréciation forcé naguère
sur ce dossier par matignon et l'elysée
aujourd'hui chacun affiche la même ligne
et c'est hubert védrine qui s'en fait le
porte parole au point où nous en sommes
l'urgence absolue c'est que les
responsables de part et d'autre trouve
d'urgence les gestes parallèle de
désescalade
pour éviter de basculer dans pi
une position certes équilibré mais
saura-t-elle entendus pour henri
hajdenberg les 48 heures à venir seront
décisives
l'actualité internationale nous offre
une nouvelle fois le deuxième gros titre
de cette édition avec l'intronisation
officielle hier à belgrade du nouveau
président yougoslave sans faste ni
décoration excessive une cérémonie qui
tranche radicalement avec celle qui
avait l'habitude de vivre la serbie sous
la dictature de milosevic
une page est vraiment tourné et ce
dimanche dans la capitale après la messe
le lieu de visite incontournable était
le parlement on y vient on y revient
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux gérard
griesbeck et henkel l'état-major de
l'armée yougoslave au complet le dernier
carré des partisans de slobodan
milosevic venu faire allégeance au
nouveau président on pourrait presque
dire qu'ils ont mangé leur képi
c'était hier au soir lors de la
prestation de serment du président
yougoslave boilly sladkov tout needs a
appelé au rassemblement du pays à la
démocratie politique sans laquelle at il
dit il n'y a pas de bonheur et de
progrès un discours banal pour un
français mais tout à fait
révolutionnaire faut un serbe
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui encore
beaucoup de belgradois sont venus
respirer l'air du changement le
parlement fédéral qui a brûlé jeudi est
devenue un lieu de pèlerinage
ce dimanche les familles se sont
déplacées
les plus anciens expliquent aux plus
jeunes c'est presque un cours
d'instruction civique devant un bâtiment
pillés et calcinée cette dame a récupéré
un souvenir un morceau de bois moitié
brûlé ce que vous voyez ici c'est notre
âme
pour moi c'est une renaissance
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas 28 ans j'ai cinq
jours j'étais là jeudi dernier avec une
amie
on a eu peur on a beaucoup couru cette
date pour représenter beaucoup de choses
si ça améliore notre vie de l'autre côté
du bâtiment
il reste encore quelques voitures de la
police
là encore on vient y pêcher quelques
souvenirs
ce n'était pas la meilleure façon de s'y
prendre mais on n'avait pas le choix
les belgradois ont vu tous ces
événements jeudi dernier à la télévision
mais aujourd'hui ils sont venus en
famille pour vérifier que tout cela est
vrai qu'ils n'ont pas rêvé que le régime
de milosevic est bien tombé c'est donc
demain que les sanctions qui frappent la
yougoslavie devrait être levé par
l'union européenne permettant ainsi un
pays exsangue après huit ans d'embargo
international de commencer sa
reconstruction la yougoslavie qui
souffre d'une situation économique
désastreuse
l'exemple à novi sad la deuxième grande
ville du pays qui a majoritairement voté
pour que sony tsar portage jérôme bunny
fille du chasselas novi sad
l'une des villes les plus touchées par
les frappes de l'otan l'année dernière
tous et pont sur le danube ont été
détruits la reconstruction de l'un
d'entre eux vient d'être terminée
étrange coïncidence la vie reprend avec
le changement de régime politique mais
quelle vie le tiers de la population est
au chômage les salaires qui était de
l'équivalent de 350 francs mensuels
avant les frappes sont tombés à 240
francs depuis un an
maman et la société saine mais comme une
pyramide avait qu un petit sommet des
gens très riches mais peu nombreux deux
sont entre 400 et 600 mille personnes
qui peuvent survivre et en bas tout le
reste du million de personnes qui sont
en dessous du minimum nécessaire pour
une vie décente pour survivre ils font
leurs courses sur les marchés parallèles
ici le marché aux puces de novi sad on y
trouve des produits à 30% moins cher que
dans les magasins
cette vendeuse s'approvisionnent en
hongrie c'est aussi le marché de ceux
qui en sont réduits à vendre leurs
effets personnels pour gagner le minimum
vital
non nous n'avons pas d'argent pour
acheter du pain et du lait nous avons
faim faim faim avant les mères de
famille donner les vêtements de leurs
enfants à des amis maintenant elles
doivent les revendre je vends pouvoir
acheter quelque chose de neuf à mes
enfants
tous ont voté pour le changement
politique peut-être la levée des
sanctions contre la serbie aura-t-elle
une incidence sur leur vie partons à
présent pour kosovo la communauté
albanaise reçoit avec une certaine
réserve les premières déclarations du
nouveau président yougoslave qui
désignèrent affirmait qu'il plaide
résolument pour un retour des serbes qui
ont fui la province
reportage à pancevo d'âne pour signer de
christian tu qui se sont mêlés ce
dimanche aux cérémonies d'un mariage
dans la communauté albanophone
dimanche c'est jour de mariage au kosovo
la campagne résonne de musique et de
tirs de joie
c'est la fête mais les changements
politiques à belgrade n'y sont pour rien
ici dans le petit village de look
il ne réjouit personne pour nous c'est
la même chose qu'aux ids milosevic
c'est le même nationalisme serbe
kostelic a le même but il était lui
aussi contre l'intervention de l'otan et
contre le droit des albanais
les albanais se sentent bien dans leur
kosovo d'aujourd'hui sous administration
internationale
or pour que je te dit ça le kosovo est
et doit demeurer servent eux au
contraire ne rêve plus que
d'indépendance naraghi ils nous ont
massacrés
ils nous ont tués ils nous ont fait les
pires choses on ne pourra plus jamais
s'entendre
plutôt mourir que vivre avec eux pas
question pour eux d'accepter un mariage
forcé avec les serbes arrangé par la
communauté internationale
alors pour les albanais que je tony ça
le démocrate est ce inquiétant parce
qu'il risque de rendre plus défendable
le point de vue des serbes
la propagande ce changement d'homme
c'est une manoeuvre dessert pour tromper
la kfor et l'otan mais je ne pense pas
que ça va marcher
je ne pense pas qu'ils vont réussir à
récupérer le kosovo cette manière dès la
chute de slobodan milosevic les journaux
albanais de pristina se sont hâtés de
publier une photo de vos is love coach
tony ça portant une arme
photo prix selon eux au prg se vaut
pendant le conflit
une manière de dire que le nouveau
président yougoslave ne vaut pas mieux
que son prédécesseur élection
présidentielle en pologne 29 millions
d'électeurs appelés à se prononcer le
chef de l'état est donné largement
gagnant seule inconnue savoir si
alexandre kouassi et ce qui sera élu dès
le premier tour les premiers résultats
officieux nous parviendrons tard dans la
soirée la campagne électorale a été
dominée par le soutien de tous les
candidats à l'entrée de la pologne dans
l'europe politique française quand on
reparle du financement occulte des
partis et notamment du rpr ce matin le
président de l'assemblée nationale en
personne raymond forni revenant sur la
sphère mairie suggère à jacques chirac
de s'expliquer devant la justice les
réactions ne se sont pas fait attendre
jean bernard schmidt chef de l'état ne
saurait dans cette enceinte de quelque
manière que ce soit faire l'objet
d'imputations à caractère personnel
rappel à l'ordre ce jour là le président
de l'assemblée nationale raymond forni
excluait toute mise en cause personnelle
du chef de l'état dans l'enceinte
parlementaire depuis les révélations sur
les affaires mettant en cause jacques
chirac ont suscité un séisme politique
aujourd'hui loin de l'hémicycle le
président de l'assemblée se permet de
critiquer je note que ce qui lui est
demandé aujourd'hui ça n'est pas de
s'expliquer sur une période où il
exerçait les fonctions de présidente
c'est de s'expliquer sur une période
antérieure à sa prise de la ville a déjà
dit qu'ils étaient des calomnies des
mensonges il a nié tout en bloc
maintenant mais le meilleur moyen c'est
précisément celui qui prend du principal
réserve de raymond forni la décision du
conseil constitutionnel accordant
l'immunité au président de la république
un avis jugé curieux et contestée selon
lui par tous une appréciation purement
politique pour les défenseurs de jacques
chirac
monsieur forni lorsque le juge
jean-pierre tournait autour de l'elysée
de monsieur françois mitterrand je n'ai
pas entendu il trouvait que la justice
n'avait pas investiguer à l'elysée quand
le titulaire était françois mitterrand
fois l'article c'est la première fois
qu'un responsable socialiste du niveau
de raymond forni s'exprime sur le statut
du président de la république
une façon de montrer que dans cette
affaire la paix est loin d'être signé la
rentrée universitaire l'occasion
d'évoquer la question du bizutage très
officiellement les enseignants selon une
directive du ministre de l'éducation
jack lang sont appelés à être vigilants
la fois pour lutter contre de telles
pratiques indignes et au besoin pour
faire appliquer les sanctions restent
les difficultés à mettre à jour au
quotidien
une autre forme de bizutage qui ne dit
pas son nom
peut être moins brutal mais tout aussi
humiliante nabila taboury alain poiré
mélange de poissons duff de petits pois
et de savon c'est sous paraît bien un
femmes tout comme le traitement auquel
doivent se soumettre ces étudiants de
classes préparatoires
ces images tournées par un amateur date
de 95
le bizutage n'était pas encore hors la
loi aujourd'hui ces actes dégradants
serait passible de 6 mois de prison et
50 mille francs d'amendé
depuis le vote de la loi il y a deux ans
et l'interdiction du bizutage les
pratiques les plus violentes semble
avoir disparu mais le mal a pris une
autre forme
un crayon énormément que les visiteurs
se cache et qu'un certain nombre de ces
week-ends d'intégration qu'on voit
fleurir un peu partout vin ne soient que
des bizutages déguisait qui se tiennent
par des établissements pendant le
week-end loin d'aider des responsables
et qu'il y ait là des pratiques que tout
à fait condamnable enfoncé la barrière
en bas apprendre à passer l'antirouille
à face à la peinture ce week-end
d'intégration n'a rien de clandestins
ces élèves de l'école d'ingénieurs de
saint-etienne sont là pour rendre
service on ses impôts ramasser des
déchets leur bizutage a au moins le
mérite d'être intelligent et utile mais
un bizutage lorsqu'il se passe mal peut
laisser des traces
conséquence la plus grave c'est que dans
la formation de futurs cadres puisque ce
sont en principe des personnes qui ont
un niveau d'éducation relativement
supérieur la main à la moyenne on
entretient une espèce de confusion entre
ce qu'est une hiérarchie de fonctionner
dans cette personne c'est à dire quand
même les journées penser que quand on
est le chef
on a un pouvoir on a une supériorité
mais mon dignité par rapport à celui qui
rêve depuis toujours en matière de
bizutage c'est l'omerta ceux qui le
pratiquent ne veulent pas témoigner ceux
qui le subissent encore moins le comité
national contre le bizutage n'hésite pas
à parler de manipulation mentale
deux nouveaux cas de vache folle dit
cela en france là dans la sarthe l'autre
en vendée c'est grâce aux nouveaux tests
et mises en place par le ministère de
l'agriculture que ces bêtes de portant
la maladie ont été découvertes au total
depuis le début de l'année il s'agit du
59e cas recensés après la catastrophe du
concorde les familles des victimes
allemandes adresse ce soir un ultimatum
à air france qui a jusqu'à vendredi
prochain pour présenter une proposition
chiffrée de dédommagement une page
sportive avec le grand prix du japon et
la victoire de ferrari après 21 ans de
patience
des milliers de supporteurs en italie en
fait aujourd'hui la fête pour célébrer
l'événement stéphane grand c'est une
étreinte qui n'en finit plus michael
schumacher et jean todt seul au monde
sur le podium de 6 du cac au firmament
tout simplement en remportant sa
huitième couronne de la saison
l'allemand s'est offert sa troisième
couronne mondiale
pourtant au départ schumi en rouge
évidemment et mika hakkinen pouvait
rêver tous les deux au titre l'allemand
rate son départ et c'est de coincer la
mclaren qui passe de justesse finalement
et comme souvent cette saison au hasard
d'un arrêt aux stands schumacher a été
le plus malin le plus rapide surtout sa
ferrari sort en tête à qui mène juste
derrière l'heure de gloire a sonné les
défis colossaux et je ne trouve pas les
mots pour exprimer ce que je ressens
c'est super de finir par une victoire
après une telle bataille jusqu'au
dernier virage
ce succès de ferrari c'est aussi celui
de jean todt arrivé à la scuderia en
1993 et qui à force de travail et de
talent a permis à ferrari de renouer
avec sa légende
la célèbre marque au cavallino son
fameux cheval cabré attendait cela
depuis 21 ans et la victoire de jody
scheckter à monza
alors forcément c'est tout le peuple
créera rist qui a fait exploser sa joie
aujourd'hui comme ici à maranello en
italie
les usines de la scuderia sont installés
depuis 1947 vite ferrari c'est grand
c'est grand c'est grandiose rouge de
bonheur aussi
les tifosi allemand dans le village de
schumacher la bière a coulé à flots pour
fêter le héros au mondial de l'auto il y
avait plus de retenue mais une qu une
habituelle quand même 20 25 minutes
d'attentes voire une demi heure pour
décrocher le sésame seule petite
déception pour les fans il n'y avait que
le modèle réduit
mais ferrari fait rêver une passion
souvent vécu par procuration car ces
bolides coûte autour d'un million de
francs pièce sur les traces de
saint-exupéry et de mermoz le rallye
aérien le plus long du monde souhaite
dix mille kilomètres dans le ciel
africain
un hommage à l'aéropostale avec ses
parcours et ses visions un signe et au
dessus du désert loïc de la mornais
guillaume fautrat
fendre le désert 20 voronine longer les
côtes aride de l'attak être seul entre
ciel et sable et surtout avaler des
killers
c'était le quotidien des aviateurs de
l'aéropostale il ya 70 ans
aujourd'hui les pilotes du rallye
toulouse saint louis du sénégal tente
humblement de refaire le parcours
empruntait mermoz ou saint-exupéry pour
tout plan de vol une course de dix mille
kilomètres aller retour sur les traces
de l'histoire de l'aviation
mais aussi compétition où chaque détail
est météo panique et marc gestion du
stress engage le sort des équipages
après le briefing ça y est c'est parti
on est à fond dans la tempête il faut
bout comme ça et quand on descend de
l'avion c'est où l'écart momie coffreur
ajoie parce qu'on a réussi l'épreuve
ces pilotes n'ont connu la nature de
l'épreuve que quelques minutes avant
leur départ
au programme aujourd'hui des tests de
navigation de précision d'atterrissage
et même quelques qcm de culture générale
et toujours cette excitante en voie
d'être accroché un petit avion six
heures durant au dessus des régions les
plus isolées de la terre
ah oui
ils sont dans un environnement inconnu
pour eux le désert c'est à 800km le
prochain héros de rome sur sips
écologiquement les marques au bout
malgré les balises de détresse les
systèmes de positionnement par
satellites les avions comme à l'époque
de l'aéropostale sont toujours aussi
fragile et insignifiant dans l'immensité
du désert
la suite des collections de
prêt-à-porter printemps-été 2001 avec
aujourd'hui sur le podium les modèles de
christian delacroix tout à fait
inattendue cette fois ci le créateur met
en lumière une femme plutôt punk
imagination chatoyantes avec des mousses
teens asymétriques et des broderies d'or
et c'était le cola bernard connard de sa
réputation d'enfant terrible de la mode
on croyait tout savoir sur christian
lacroix son enfance arlésienne ces
mélanges maîtriser ces superpositions
son goût de l'accumulation oui mais cet
après-midi et sans lacroix a déchiré ses
propres règles du jeu avec des épaules
dénudées des robes la serrer mais alors
si s est une nouvelle salle lacroix
femme d'un diplomate pourquoi pas une
ambassadrice elle même qui est un petit
peu obligé de sortir des brumes de stone
univers qu'il soit parisien londonien
wire que quand un petit peu à contre
courant d'un petit peu à part qui se
retrouvent dans des pays effectivement
exotiques tout très torride
les marques de luxe se joue sous le
signe de la transgression
c'est annie pomme pour laisser quelques
traces d'épinglés à nourrice de chêne
véritable attitude sociale l'accessoire
domine un style radicalement opposées la
tendance bourgeoise tiré à quatre
épingles un vent de rébellion souffle
mais que le maître sera sur l'impact
visuel plus réussi très réussi
elle a une voix de cristal son dernier
disque sur vivaldi atteindre des records
de vente cecilia bartoli a hérité de la
passion du chant de sa famille elle est
italienne
elle a déjà toutes les qualités d'une
diva apparemment sans les défauts son
portrait de ning bas rouges patrick voix
rencontre autour d'un gâteau
d'anniversaire
william christie et cecilia bartoli vous
avez déjà vu le même genre de complicité
avec d'autres solistes d'empathie
vous oui mais pas avec avec cette
intensité que je vis avec elle
la cantatrice chante comme elle respire
j'ai commencé à faire de vocaliser comme
ça que nous faisons avec ma mère pensé
comme un enjeu plus tôt ce n'était pas
sérieux de tous et petit à petit j'ai
découvert que j'avais que j'avais un
instrument alors c'est quand même
étonnant mais moi j'arrive à faire deux
choses comme ça c'est pas mal c'est pas
possible à 20 ans cécilia est remarqué
par ricardo mutti karajan barenboim les
ingrédients du succès talent et hérédité
avec des parents eux-mêmes soliste à
l'opéra
j'espérais qu'elle devienne musicienne
parce que j'aime la musique je n'aurais
jamais pensé qu'elle devient
récemment
rien de facile dans cette carrière
fulgurante
à 34 ans elle sélectionne les partitions
et impose son audace
point de risques ça veut dire quand même
interprété essayer d'interpréter dû
donner une interprétation et ça et c'est
impératif de faire ça elle peut pas
faire seulement les lectures il faut
quand même donner sa propre vision de
second cents par rapport à la musique
quand on chante
parce vocalises la jeune diva séduit le
maître du baroque et attire un public
sans cesse plus important cinéma avec la
sortie mercredi prochain de memento à un
thriller qui raconte l'histoire d'un
homme qui n'a pas de mémoire immédiate
parce qu'elle défend frédéric de la ré
so far east of life ne me souvenais
essayer un quart d'heure non je me
souviens pas mais je sais comment je
m'appelle lui c'est léonard il ne se
souvient pas de ce qu'il a fait quelques
minutes auparavant tout s'efface
si cette conversation dure un peu trop
je serai bientôt plus comment il a
commencé ce n'est pas de l'amnésie mais
une autre maladie qui affecte la mémoire
est le point de départ de ce thriller
captivant
le spectateur est mis d'emblée dans la
peau d'un homme qui ne sait pas ce qui
vient de se passer
le film est donc monté à l'envers et
remonte les temps qui vous a fait tu as
toi
que le spectateur vit pleinement
l'aventuré je ne voulais pas qu'ils
sachent la seule solution c'était de
raconter l'histoire à l'envers comme une
série de flèches on commence par là et
on remontre la chronologie à ce prêt
n'est engagé
on commence donc par voir un meurtre
puis les minutes qui ont précédé ce
meurtre puis le moment qui aura précédé
ce moment et ainsi de suite jusqu'à ce
que le spectateur reconstitue 24 heures
de la vie de cet homme seul moyen pour
leonardo volé quelques petits souvenirs
à l'oubli seul refaire pour le public
des photos ateliers et des tatouages
autant de pense-bête gravé à même la
peau autant d'éléments du puzzle qui
s'emboîtent petit à petit
samassa dire la taille l'autre jour
quelqu'un m'a demandé le pensez vous pas
que le réalisateur suppose que le tubik
est intelligent et j'ai répondu
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il a raison de
supposer que le public avec intelligent
comme fahradi
film à suspense réflexion sur la mémoire
aventure psychologique pour le
spectateur
memento est une incroyable richesse il a
raflé trois prix du public du jury et de
la critique au festival de deauville
on aura rarement vu une telle unanimité
je me souviens pas les fondateurs des
éditions bordas qui l'on doit notamment
les célèbres manuels de français lagarde
et michard ce fondateur donc est mort
jeudi dernier 87 ans ça n'est
qu'aujourd'hui que nous avons appris son
décès c'est la fin de ce journal nous en
rappelle le principal titre au
proche-orient- quelques fragiles signes
d'apaisement
il est assez rare a pas de demande la
reconstruction du tombeau de joseph
saccagé hier une cellule de crise entre
israéliens et palestiniens était décidée
sur la question de la sécurité à gaza
mais la situation reste terriblement
préoccupante ehud barak accentue la
pression sur la syrie et l'autorité
palestinienne dans un instant la météo
isabelle martinet 20h50 votre série
urgences avec des inédits 0,35 le
dernier journal jean claude renoult 13h
le journal de gérard holtz à 20h vous
retrouverez claude sérillon je vous
remercie de votre attention excellente
cinq soirées so france